there's a lot of excitement about
because we've got results from the first
vaccine against covid19
pfizer has announced that its
anti-coronavirus vaccine
developed in partnership with german
company beyond tech is 90
effective it was thought that we might
get a vaccine that was
40 percent or 50 effective so to get
90 percent in these early results is
really
quite astonishing
this vaccine is unlike any that's been
developed in the past
it's based on a new technology called
mrna
that's messenger rna so instead of using
a piece of the virus or a dead virus or
attenuated virus
this vaccine actually puts in the
genetic
code into the body which is thought to
be a lot safer
so the body thinks that the virus is
there it thinks it's being attacked
and it mounts an immune response with
antibodies and hopefully t
cells as well so if it's licensed this
is going to be the very first vaccine
using this technology it will also be
the fastest one
ever to have been approved the mumps
vaccine was developed very fast and that
took
five years this is taking less than one
year
from the lab bench through to use in
humans
the world health organization has said
that the most vulnerable people
in every country must have the vaccine
first
and that's going to include healthcare
workers in a lot of countries
in the uk the first priority is going to
be for
care home residents and the people who
work there
because it's been very clear that
they've been at high risk of dying from
this disease
after that come the nhs workers and the
over 80s
and then progressively younger and
younger age groups down to the age of
50.
that's the first phase and the
government scientists say that that
should cover 99
of those people who are actually at risk
of dying from this disease
we haven't had the full details yet from
the clinical trials
so there are a lot of things we don't
know we don't know if it works
differently in different age groups for
instance
and we don't know how long the effects
of vaccination are going to last
but crucially we don't know if the
vaccine is going to stop
transmission of the disease we know that
it stops people becoming ill
but we don't know if it stops them
becoming infected
and we don't know if it stops them
infecting other people so transmitting
it to others
this vaccine does have one major
drawback
which is that it has to be kept in
what's called ultra cold chain
that means it must be stored in freezers
at around
minus 70 to minus 80 degrees so that's
going to be a serious problem
for some of the low-income countries who
certainly don't have
freezers of that sort it may even be a
problem for some of the affluent
countries
who will have to step up their cold
chain also
you need two doses of this vaccine three
weeks apart
that means that you won't be protected
for about 28 days
after the first jab because it takes
about seven days to take effect
there is a lot of concern about these
vaccines simply because of the speed at
which they're being developed
but the regulators have said they will
not cut corners
and that for them safety is paramount
the uk has pre-ordered 40 million doses
of this vaccine
and europe and the united states between
them have ordered hundreds of millions
as well
pfizer and biontech have said that they
will manufacture 50 million doses
in 2020 and then a further 1.3 billion
in 2021
that's clearly not enough for the 7
billion people on the planet
so we will need other vaccines too but
also
some vaccines will have strengths that
others don't they will all be slightly
different
and some may work better in some
populations than others
for instance they may work better in the
elderly population
life won't be going back to normal just
yet we've got a lot of people to
vaccinate
and before that we don't know all the
details of how this vaccine will work
however these are very promising results
rather better than most people expected
so i think there's no doubt we're on the
road to normality
we just don't know how long that road is